ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีนักเรียนทุก
คนทั้ง 10 คน
ใส่ค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะผู้หญิงวันนี้วัน
เสาร์ค่ะ
วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
26 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมเดือนมีนาคมปีพตตเท่าไหร่คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงมีวงตอนนี้เวลา
16:00 นตรงค่ะ 4 โมงตรงนะคะใช่ค่ะผู้
หญิงวันนี้ครูเอ๋ไม่มีคำถามอ๋อวันนี้ครู
หญิงมีคำถามค่ะครู S ผู้หญิงมีคำถามสวิง
ถามใครคะ
ถามครูเอ๋ค่ะ
ถามครูเอ๋
เพราะไม่ถามนักเรียน
ครูหญิงถามนักเรียนแล้วนักเรียนแบบเขียน
เขียนคำตอบให้ครูหญิงแล้วลูกครูหญิงถาม
นักเรียนว่าอะไรคะถามนักเรียนว่านักเรียน
ชอบดื่มอะไรดื่ม
น่ารักมี L มีเครื่องดื่มมีหลอดหลอดเข้า
ปากแล้วก็
ดูดอันนี้ดื่ม
ดื่ม of ผู้หญิงถามนักเรียน10คนวันนัก
เรียนชอบดื่มอะไรค่ะทรายนักเรียนมีกระดาษ
แล้วก็เขียนให้ผู้หญิงค่ะแต่ครูเอ๋เนี่ย
ไม่รู้นักเรียน
ไม่รู้ไม่เห็นผู้หญิงด้วยผู้หญิงด้วย
ชอบดื่มอะไรก็กูเองไม่รู้
วันนี้ครูหญิงก็เลยมีคำถาม
ดูหญิงจะมีรูป
รูปเครื่องดื่มค่ะถ้าให้ครูเอ๋ดู
ค่ะแล้วถามครูก็ต่ายถามว่า
ครูเอ๋คิดว่าใคร
ใครชอบดื่มเครื่องดื่มนี้โอเคค่ะ
คู๋ขอดูมีเครื่องดื่มอะไร
คุณต้อง Share  screen นะคะ a ไม่มี
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงให้มันใหญ่
โอเคฮะเองเห็นแล้ว
ใช่กูเห็นแล้วค่ะค่ะอันนี้น้ำแอปเปิ้ล
น้ำน้ำแอปเปิ้ลน้า
ครูเอ๋แอมเพิลมีน้ำใส่ค่ะเดี๋ยวนะคะครู
หญิงได้ๆเอ๋
ได้ไหมอ่ะโทรหาครูเหนเขียนได้ไหมได้อัน
นี้แอปเปิ้ล
แก้วแล้วก็น้ำแอปเปิ้ลแล้วก็หลอดนะคะใช่
ผู้หญิงจะถามครูเอ๋ว่าอะไรคะครูหญิงถาม
ว่าครูเอ๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มน้ำแอปเปิล
ดื่มน้ำแอปเปิลผู้หญิงด้วยนะรวมครูหญิง
ด้วยนะอ๋อลุงผู้หญิงด้วยนะคะอ่ามี 11 คน
ใช่ไหม 11 คนติดคนอ่า
ครูเอกคิดว่าต้องเป็นผู้หญิง
คุยกันบอกว่าเป็นผู้หญิงถูกฆ่าผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงมีคุณลิซ่ามีคุณประวีณามีคุณแคะมีผู้
หญิง 4 คนไป 4 คนนะคะ 4 คนเอ่อ
[เพลง]
มีหินไหมคะ
กี่คนคะกี่คนชอบน้ำแอปเปิ้ล
1 คนเป็นผู้หญิง 1 คนชอบดื่มน้ำแอปเปิล
ดื่มน้ำแอปเปิลหรอคุณประวีณาคุณใบ้ไม่ใช่
ฝรั่ง
ก็เหลือคุณปวีณาคุณลิซ่าครูหญิงตายเหลือ 3
คนครูเอกคิดว่า
คิดว่าคุณลิซ่า 2 ดื่มน้ำแอปเปิลค่ะใช่
ไหมคะไม่ใช่ค่ะผิดค่ะหรอ
สิทธิ์ชาตอบใหม่ได้ไหมได้ที่เหลือครูหญิง
กับคุณประวีณาผู้หญิงกับคุณปวีณาผู้หญิง
ไม่ลืมหรอก
คุณประวีณาชอบดื่มน้ำแอปเปิลทัวร์
เพชรราชไม่ใช่หรอใครไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงหรอ
ผู้หญิงชอบดื่มน้ำแอปเปิลเหรอคะครูเองไม่
รู้ครูเอคะเครื่องบินเนี่ย
เครื่องบินเนี่ยเสิร์ฟน้ำแอปเปิ้ลอาหร่อย
มาก
หรอ
Japan  Airlines ค่ะครูเอ๋หิวหรือเปล่า
คิดอร่อย
Japan  J  L ไหมแจวไหมคะ Japan  Airlines
น้ำแอปเปิ้ลอร่อยมากก็
หาย
ผู้หญิงค่ะครูเอ๋ค่ะผู้หญิงที่ชอบดื่มน้ำ
แอปเปิลนะคะไดร์ค่ะไม่ใช่นักเรียนไม่ใช่
ค่ะ
อ่ะอันนี้เป็นโซดา
น้ำโซดาค่ะอ๋อตรงนี้ Soda  ago เอกวาดให้
ก็ได้
อันนี้ Soda แล้วก็เอามะนาวจ่าย Soda อัน
นี้อะไรคะน้ำแข็งค่ะน้ำแข็งใสที่มี
น้ำมะนาวโซดาหรือสละมะนาวโอเคคายครูเอ๋
คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มโซดามะนาวโซดามะนาวหรอ
ค่ะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงหินให้กูเอ๋คู่หญิงผู้
หญิง
แต่ผู้ชาย
เป็นผู้ชายเป็นผู้ชายมีหินเดียวหรอคะ
พิมพ์ที่ 2 เลยอายเอเชีย
ผู้ชายฝรั่งผู้ชายฝรั่งร้องมันเอาโซดาผู้
ชายฝรั่งมีคนแรกมีคน Robert มีคุณ John
มีคุณเคล้ามีคุณ John คนนะผู้หญิงคะพี่
คุณอาใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่อเมริกา
โอเคคุณคุณแม่ไปคุณ John ไปเหลือคุณโร
เบิร์ตคุณ John คุณไอ้คุณเคล้าร้าน 3 คน
เดี๋ยวสามคนคู่ a  Kid คุณ
ใครล่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสันชอบดื่มน้ำ
มะนาวโซดา
โป้ค่าเห็ดอีกแล้วเหรอค่ะติดค่ะอ่ะ
เหลือคุณเคล้ากับคุณจอนจอนสวีเดนหรอคะใส่
ค่ะตัวเองโอเคคุณเคล้าค่ะคนเขา
เธอกัน
เอกดีใจมากดีใจ
เก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋
ดีใจดีใจคุณเค้าชอบดื่มน้ำมะนาวโซดาหนา
ค่ะจะเครื่องดื่มต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋อะไรคะ
โอ้โอ๋กาแฟร้อน
ใต้กาแฟร้อน
ในรูปนะคะก็จะมี
มีอะไรบ้างคะเมล็ดกาแฟมีแต่ค่ะกาแฟร้อน
ถ้วยกาแฟอันนี้อะไรค่ะ
ร้านรองถ้วยกาแฟค่ะเป็นสีเขียวดีกว่าเนาะ
นี่นา
จานรองถ้วยกาแฟ
ค่ะคะ
หู
รู้จักได้คู่หูถ้วยกาแฟอันนี้ก็หู
เบาคนอันนี้หูถ้วยกาแฟนะคะอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋เอ๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มกาแฟร้อนท่อใคร
ชอบดื่มกาแฟร้อนพรุ่งนี้นะคะครูเอ๋เป็น
ผู้ชายผู้ชาย
อ่าโอเคคุณคุณเค้าไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะสายๆค่ะ
เป็นผู้ชายอ่า
อังกฤษแน่ๆเลยไม่ใช่ฝรั่งเอา
คุณทาดาชิ
[เพลง]
ถูกค่ะครูเอ๋เก่งมากขอขอบคุณคุณทานาชิ
เป็นคนญี่ปุ่นค่ะรู้คนญี่ปุ่นชอบดื่มกาแฟ
นะคะหนูผู้หญิงคู๋ลืมกาแฟตรงนี้อะไรอ่ะ
ไหนคะล้อฟอร์ดอ่อไม่ใช่หะควันค่ะจะวัน
คว้าเราก็ตรงนี้อะฟองใช่มั้ยกองกาแฟทอง
กาแฟตรงนี้
มี
ควันนะคะเมื่อวัน
เก่งมากเก่งตัวเองรบกวนนะคะผู้หญิงได้
ค่ะเรื่องดื่มต่อไปค่ะขลุ่ยเดี๋ยวหญิง
เคลียร์ให้ก็ได้ค่ะเครื่องดื่มต่อไปเป็น
อะไรคะ
กาแฟเย็นกาแฟเย็นนะคะ
ถึง
ครูเอ๋มีอะไรบ้างในรูปอ่ะในรูปหรอคะในรูป
มีมีโต๊ะค่ะ
ไหนคะโต๊ะ
อันนี้ครับโต๊ะ
โต๊ะอาอันนี้อะไรคะ
ไหนคะตัวนกแก้วค่ะแล้วอะไรคะแก้ว
พลาสเตอร์แก้วกาแฟแล้วกับแก้วพลาสติกค่ะ
อันนี้อะไรคะ
หลอดค่ะแล้วก็อันนี้อะไรค่ะร้านน้ำแข็ง
ค่ะเดี๋ยวก่อนข้างในเป็น
กาแฟ
ตรงก้นแก้วนมเป็นนมค่ะน้องนะคะน้องเก้า
ถ้วยนี้เรียกว่าอะไรคะตาแฟเย็นกาแฟเย็นนะ
คะบ้านจะมีชื่ออะไรนะโอเคเอสเพรสโซ
อเมริกาโนคาปูชิโนริคาปูชิโน่ลาเต้นะกาแฟ
เย็นครูเอ๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มกาแฟเย็นสาย
ยืนหรออีก
เป็นผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายหรอไม่ใช่ฝรั่งใช่ปะเป็นฝรั่งขนม
ฝรั่งพี่เดี๋ยวเหลือใครมั่งเนี่ยอ่า
ฝรั่งหรอมีคุณมีคุณ
อาโรเบิร์ตคุณแบรคขึ้น rat จรคุณ John
คุณคราวคุณเขาไปแล้วมี 4 คนค่ะครูเอกคิด
คนไม่เจาะ
จอนจอนไหน
เท็กซัสจรเท็กซัส
ใช่มั้ย
ไม่รู้
ไม่รู้กูเอกคิดเฉยๆใคร
เก่งว่าเก่งมากค่ะคุณ John เท็กซัสนะคะ
ชอบดื่มกาแฟเย็นคุณ John แท้ๆ
เรียกดื่มต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋โอ๋ไปเป็นอะไร
ครับครูเอ๋
อาชาเขียวมัทฉะใช่ๆค่ะชาเขียวมัทฉะผู้
หญิงครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ชื่อเลยนะเนี่ยไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะค่ะอันนี้นะเป็นเป็นทุกคนนะคะ
อันนี้เป็นใบชา chacha ใช่ไหมคะใบชาอัน
นี้เป็นอะไรนะคะหากเป็นถ้วยถ้วยชาข้างใน
เป็นอะไรคะเป็นชาค่ะน้ำชาอันนี้ก็เป็น
ถ้วยข้างในเป็นอะไรคะผงชาถุงชา
แล้วก็อันนี้ก็เป็น
กากา
ชกาคิดว่าข้างในเป็นน้ำร้อน
อะนี้เป็นหูอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะไหนคะ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋คุยกับรู้ไหมที่แปลกมัทฉะๆ
พี่น้องชาผงช้านิดชื่อมัทฉะคานี้เป็น
สำหรับตัดใช่ไหมอ่ะแล้วก็ใส่แล้วก็เคน้ำ
ร้อนแค่นี้กำร้อนใส่ระบอบเทน้ำร้อน
อันนี้
ไม่แน่ใจครูเอ๋ไม่รู้ชื่ออะไรค่ะเอ๋เรียก
แปลง
เลขแปลง
เอาไว้ตี
ขอโทษตีชาที่อยู่ในถ้วยนี้หรอคะที่ใส่น้ำ
ร้อนแล้วใช่เอาไว้
tpt มัดศ
อ่ะ
ครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มชาเขียว
มัทฉะที่เหลือใครนั่นแหละคุณแบรคผู้หญิง
หรือผู้ชายค่ะเป็นผู้ชายเป็นฝรั่ง
ผู้ชายฝรั่งก็เลยคุณแบรดคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ
John สวีเดนหมดแล้วค่ะเดี๋ยวสามคนเป็น
ทาดาชิไปแล้วคุณ John เท็กซัสไปแล้ว
คุณเอ๋ได้ยินอังกฤษอังกฤษชอบกินชาอังกฤษ
โอเคคุณ John สวีเดน
คู๋ไม่รู้แต่กูเอกคิดเอ่อคนอังกฤษก็ต้อง
เป็นเออเกรย์ใช่ไหมคะอะไรค่ะ
อเมริกา
ไม่แน่ใจโอเคคุณ John สวีเดน
เก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋ขอบคือ
คุณ John สวีเดนน่ะไปแล้วนะคะคู๋นี้เขา
เดาเก่งนะเนี่ย
อา
ต่อไปนั่งดื่มอะไรคะโอ้วอะไรคะครูเอ๋รู้
ไหมเครื่องดื่มชื่ออะไรชาดำเย็นไม่อาย n
a ไม่รู้จะพูดไม่ดื่มไงไม่ดื่มชาเย็นค่ะ
ถ้าเย็น
ลุงเอ๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มชาเย็น
ไม่เอาหินเหรอคะผู้หญิงใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเป็น
ผู้หญิงครูเอ๋เนี่ยดู YouTube แล้วกูเอก
ก็รู้หนึ่งประเทศชอบดื่มชาโอ้โห
ครูเอ๋คิดว่าใครคิดว่าเป็นผู้หญิงมาจาก
ประเทศอินเดีย
คุณประวีณาชอบดื่มชาเย็นใช่ไหมคะ
กูได้ยังไง
นักเรียนจะคิดว่าคุยเอ๋ผู้หญิงบอกไม่ได้
บอกนะกูยังไม่
ไม่ได้บอกครูเอ๋เอ๋ไม่รู้เลยครูหญิงรู้คน
เดียว
เอกเก่งมาก
เย้เอาๆๆเก่งมากคุณประวีณาชอบดื่มชาเย็น
ค่ะขอบคุณค่ะเก่งมากต่อไปดูแลตัวเอเอาไป
เป็นอะไรคะอันนี้ครูเอ๋
ไม่รู้ไหมชามะนาว
ชัยค่ะค่ะชามะนาวนะคะอันนี้เป็น
อันนี้เป็นมะนาวค่ะอันนี้เป็นชานะคะเพราะ
มะนาว
แก้วอันนี้อะไรนะคะผู้หญิงไหนคะน้ำแข็ง
ค่ะแล้วอันนี้อะไรคะ
ใบสะระแหน่ค่ะสะระแหน่ชามะนาว
ครูเอ๋อยากฟังหินไหมอยากฟังเพราะว่า
เหลืองมีผู้หญิงมีผู้ชายใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่า
ครูเอ๋ต้องคิดใช่ไหมคะว่าใครชอบดื่มชา
มะนาวตอนนี้เราก็จะมีผู้ชาย
2 คน
อ่ะค่ะอยู่ได้ 2 คนนะคะมึงโรเบิร์ตคุณเท
แล้วมีพูดผู้หญิง
มีคุณลิซ่าแล้วก็คุณแคทมีผู้ชายสามคนขอ
โทษค่ะผู้หญิงลืมคุณแบรด
เดี๋ยวนะโอ้ผู้หญิงละ 1 คนใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวสองคนแต่ว่าชาวมะนาวเนี่ยไม่ใช่ผู้
หญิงค่ะครูเอ๋เป็นผู้ชายที่ชอบดื่มชาว
มะนาวมีคุณโรเบิร์ตกับคุณ
แม่แอ๊ดแล้วก็คุณเต็งมี 3 คน
3 คนหรอเป็นฝรั่งฝรั่งเฮ้ยเป็นฝรั่งออก
แบบฝรั่งอ่า
อังกฤษไหม
อังกฤษอ่ะจะทำเอริกาอังกฤษอเมริกา
[เพลง]
คิดว่าคุณ
โรเบิร์ตค่ะยืน Robert อังกฤษใครชอบช้า
แต่ผู้หญิงดูก่อนนะ
ถูกเธอ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ใจค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตชอบดื่มชามะนาวครูเอกคิด
อังกฤษในอังกฤษชอบดื่มค่ะค่ะหนูเก่งมาก
เรื่องดื่มต่อไปค่ะครูเอ๋นี่มัน
อะไรคะนมค่ะนมนมนะคะอ่ะอ่ะอันนี้เป็น
เป็นอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงไหนคะเป็นขวดก็ยังขา
ขวดนมข้างในคือนมตรงนี้คืออะไรคะฝาขวดค่ะ
อันนี้เป็นอะไรนะคะขวดอันนี้แก้วค่ะแก้ว
สงสารแก้วครอบขวดวางบนอะไรคะวางบนผ้าค่ะ
วันผ้าละอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะ
ดอกไม้ค่ะค่าดอกไม้แก้วนมขวดนมวางบนอะไร
คะวางบนโต๊ะค่ะโต๊ะทำจากอะไรคะโต๊ะทำจาก
ไม้ค่ะทำจากไม้นะคะจะอ่ะเนี้ยต้นไม้แล้ว
ก็ไม้
นมหรอ
รู๋คิดว่าใครชอบดื่มนมเหลือคุณแคทคุณเสีย
ถ้าคุณแต่คุณแบรคเอาหินไหมคะ
ผู้ชายคุยถามให้ผู้ชายใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะผู้ชาย
คุณเตะ
ไม่รู้
กูเองคิดไปไปออกแต่ฉีดอาจเป็นตำรวจ
ใช่ไหม
ต้องแข็งแรง
ดื่มนมแข็งแรง
ใส่ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋คุณเตชอบดื่มนมหาคุณแต่
ชอบดื่มนมใส่ค่ะอ่ะต่อไปนะคะเครื่อง
ดื่มต่อไป
น้ำมะพร้าว
ตอบเลยได้ไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋ครูเอกคิดถ้าใครชอบดื่มน้ำมะพร้าว
ไม่เห็นแล้วนะเพราะว่าเหลือ 1  2  3  3
คนคิดว่าเป็นผู้หญิง
ใช่ไหม
อ้าวไม่บอกว่าไม่ใช่ก็รู้สิ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
คุยไว้มียินคิดว่าเป็นคุณคุณคุณแคทค่ะคุณ
แชทใช่ไหมคะใช่
ผิดค่ะไม่ได้คุณขับรถไม่ใช่คุณ Cash หมอ
บอกว่ากินรู้ใช่ไหมคุณ Black  in  rare
ใช่ไหมคะ
ถูก
ก็ถูก 50%  1 จ่ายน้ำมะพร้าวนะคุณแร้ชอบ
ดื่มน้ำมะพร้าวลูกเอกก็ชอบดื่มน้ำมะพร้าว
นะคะนี่ปีอะจะบ้างอ่ะครับครูเอ๋ในรูปน้ำ
มะพร้าวเนี่ยไอ้หินอย่างนี้
จะเล่นเกมอย่างเดียวเป็ดทอดเล่นเกมมีดอก
ลีลาวดีเอาแล้วสี่ม่วงดอกอะไรคะสีม่วงสี
ดอกกล้วยไม้
ดอกลีลาวดีดอกกล้วยไม้เป็นดอกไม้นะมีดอก
ไม้ 2 อย่างมีดอกลีลาวดีใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็
ดอกกล้วยไม้ดอกลีลาวดีมี 1  2
3  4  5
ดอกเลียวดีมีทั้งหมด 5 ดอกนะคะแล้วก็มี
มะพร้าว
ไงอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะผู้หญิงไหนคะเนี้ย
เปลือก
แล้วหรอคะมีเปลือกมะพร้าวค่ะหัวใจไว้
เปลือกมะพร้าวค่ะมีรถวันที่ก่อน
ต่อไปแล้วอันนี้เป็นอะไรคะสีน้ำตาลน้ำตาล
สีน้ำตาลน้ำตาลข้างในเปลือกแล้วก็น้อกะลา
มะพร้าวค่ะลามะพร้าวแล้วสีขาวนะคะเนื้อ
มะพร้าวค่ะแล้วตรงนี้อะไรคะข้างในสุดน้ำ
มะพร้าวน้ำมะพร้าวนะคะตอนนี้ทำน้ำหมัก
ดื่มใช่ไหมคะนาย
มีอะไรอีกมีอะไรอีกครูเอ๋เอ๋เหลือ 2 คน
หามีสองคนก็จะมีน้ำส้ม
แล้วก็เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงเปิดอีก 1 อย่างนะคะ
ครูเอ๋มันจะไม่ขึ้นเนาะโอเคโอเคมันก็เลย
โอเคโอเคกูอ่ะรู้
น้ำส้มผู้ช่วยเอกคิดว่าใครชอบดื่มน้ำส้ม
คุณแคทค่ะ
สุดเท่า
ทำไมอ่ะคุณแค่เป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงชอบดื่ม
น้ำ 2 เขามีผู้หญิงซ่าก็เป็นผู้หญิงใช่ๆ
[เพลง]
ลืมเมื่อกี้คุณอะไรไปแล้วคุณ Bad ไปใช่
ไหมช่วยเหลือคุณลิซ่ากับคุณ Cash
ออยอย่าลืมโอเคคุณลิซ่าค่ะคุณลิซ่าชอบ
ดื่มน้ำส้มคั้นเป็นน้ำส้มคันนะคะก็จะมี
เนี่ยนะคะค่ะมีน้ำส้มอันนี้เป็นส้มราคา
อันนี้เป็นที่ฉันน้ำหมูๆค่ะอ่ะอ่ะ
คะแล้วก็เครื่องดื่มสุดท้ายอันนี้คุณแคท
ชอบดื่มน้ำสตรอน้ำสตรอว์เบอร์รี่ปานี
แอดนะคะอ้วน
ทรายค่ะหมดแล้วแล้ว
ครูเอ๋ล่ะคะครูเอ๋เอ๋ชอบดื่มอะไรเก๋นี่
น้ำอะไรคะครูเอ๋น้ำลิ้นจี่
กินี่ที่มีลิ้นจี่นะงาบพี่ว่านะครับคือ
เด่นมีไหมนี่ทานดีค่ะนี่ค่ะลิ้นจี่พ่อมี
นะมีลิ้นจี่ kuai ชอบดื่มน้ำลิ้นจี่ชาติ
ดื่มน้ำมะพร้าวชอบดื่มน้ำส้ม
หมูพูดเลยชอบดื่มน้ำมากๆผลไม้
มาใหม่ค่ะผลไม้
ทุเรียนนะคะไม่ได้น้ำสับปะรดออกน้ำ
แอปเปิ้ลต่อค่ะน้ำชมพู่ชอบข่าน้ำกล้วย
ไม่ต้อง
น้ำทุเรียนออกรูเอชอบดื่มน้ำผลไม้น้องคำ
สั่งนักเรียนชอบดื่มอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอกได้
นะคะ
ก็วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนอะเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยว
เจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]